welcome to exploring computing
today's video is digital music
part 5 perfect music and alternative
format
so in this video we're going to take a
look at some alternative ways of storing
your music we've seen that mp3 files
and its related cousins like aac and
wma lose information is there a way we
can store our music and have better
sounding files
well there is and this particular format
has been gaining a lot in popularity
it's called flak it stands for free
lossless audio codec
apple and microsoft have their own
versions
that have similar characteristics
basically what flack does is it takes
the original cd audio
and it compresses it but similar to the
png files we saw when we were talking
about images
the flat compression does not lose any
information so
if you're using flac your flac file
should sound every bit
as good as the original cd now i should
caution you and this is why i had the
question mark in the
original title for this video you are
still
digitizing your music so you know the
original music was digitized there are
people
that don't think 44.1 kilohertz with
16-bit sound is good enough
and in your homework you'll get to play
around with a couple alternative
formats that store more bits and have
a higher sampling rate but those really
haven't taken off but
as far as what you can do with most
digital recordings that are available to
you today
flac is probably your best choice so
here we can see the comparison of
how much space a five-minute flag song
takes
versus a five-minute mp3 song versus a
cd audio song and we can see that
the size of the flag file 35.67
megabytes is actually
a lot closer to the 50.47 megabytes of
the original cd audio file than it is to
the four and a half megabytes for mp3
so we're not saving that much space
we're saving some space but not a huge
amount of space but the good news is
if your dogs listen to your music and
they miss those
really high tones that the mp3 cuts off
with flack they'll be able to hear them
all
okay our next format is actually quite
interesting
i'm gonna play you our original copy of
beethoven's fifth symphony briefly
[Music]
and here's beethoven's fifth symphony
played with a different
file format let's see what you think of
this one
[Music]
well what did you think which one did
you like better so some of you are
thinking
why in the world would i want to use
that second file format
and that's actually a really great
question well here's the answer
in the original that we listened to
beethoven's fifth symphony was being
stored as a sound wave
and we've been talking about what you
can do with these sound waves
through the entire video sequence but
that
second recording of beethoven's fifth
was actually something quite different
that was a midi file and what midi files
do
is they store the individual notes
rather than storing the sound wave so
this has a number of advantages
first of all simply from a file space
perspective the midi file takes up much
much less space than a sound file does
keep in mind that with the sound file
we're
you know we've got 44 100 samples per
second and so if a file is just a couple
seconds that's a huge number of samples
if you compare that to how many notes
those couple seconds represent
well they don't represent that many
notes and so you can certainly store
a midi file much less space but that's
not the real point of the midi file
the real point of the midi file is this
what we're seeing here is this is a
program called
songworks and it's designed to work with
and manipulate midi files and so you can
see when we're working with a midi file
we're thinking of the music as
individual notes we're able to
manipulate the individual notes and
we can see the individual notes and so
if you're a composer
or musician you may find that midi files
are much more useful for your purposes
than the formats based on sound waves
that we've been taking a look at
like cd audio mp3
and even flag so that's it for this week
next week we're going to take a look at
computer hardware
cs106e is going to go into deep dive on
how central processing unit works and
how computer memory works
and cs105 is going to
start off with a look at computer
hardware and then move on to take a look
at how the internet works
i look forward to seeing you then
you